rodez abîmé véhicules embourbés un
simple trajet qui se transforme en un
véritable périple pour le cardinal
centrafricain dieudonné à palanga près
de 100 kilomètres seulement séparent la
piste de birao et la ville de ouandda
djallé située dans le nord du pays
pourtant le cardinal et son équipe ont
mis plus de quatre heures pour parcourir
cette distance
c'est de cette partie du territoire que
proviennent la majorité des groupes
rebelles présents centrafrique depuis
des décennies un drame s'était déjà
produit ici tous les villages autour de
nous ont déjà subi la guerre merci aux
autorités qui ont envoyé des forces à
luanda pour protéger aujourd'hui la
population
il n'y a plus de problème les habitants
et les forces entendent bien ici on n'a
déjà pas d'eau potable pas d'hôpital
quand un enfant est malade à ou honda il
faut faire plusieurs kilomètres
ou bien tu le perds en route en plus de
ça la guerre encore on demande plutôt de
l'aide pour le développement de notre
région
nous sommes aussi des humains depuis
quelques semaines l'armée centrafricaine
appuyé par la russie le rwanda avance
dans le pays pour libérer les zones
occupées par les rebelles
ces derniers menacent de prendre le
pouvoir et était même arrivé jusqu'aux
portes de la capitale centrafricaine
bangui en janvier dernier dans leur
repli les groupes armés ont prévu de
converger vers la région du nord à
majorité musulmane qui a souvent été en
proie aux violences
je viens tout le temps à l'église
catholique ici mes frères prêtres aussi
viennent régulièrement chez moi à la
mosquée on discute pour voir quoi faire
pour maintenir la paix pour le moment ce
sont les groupes armés le gouvernement
qui doivent voir comment nous ramener
cette paix s'il décide de s'entendre
cette paix va revenir une paix que
défend également l'archevêque de bangui
dieudonné à palanga
ce dernier s'est rendu dans cette région
menacée de centrafrique afin de parer
d'éventuels conflits entre les
communautés chrétienne et musulmane
cette visite fut aussi une augmentation
sur les politiques dans le sol
envie de signer un accord rencontrer les
amis pourquoi créant des mais je vais
m'organiser
comme et estompe ses forces vives autour
de cet apport pour encourager d un musée
à sortir de cette situation le pays si
sa visite dans la région a été brève le
cardinal a tenu à rappeler la dimension
politique de cette dernière alors que le
second tour des législatives
centrafricaines doit se dérouler ce
dimanche dans un climat incertain